january 2022 small groups of men start
arriving in ukraine from africa they're
there on holiday to visit family to see
their friends whatever sounds most
believable they speak ukrainian they
look ukrainian some even carry ukrainian
passports they blend in perfectly except
nothing i told you about these men is
true they're not ukrainian they're not
students or businessmen coming to visit
their friends and family there are
undercover russian mercenaries paid
fighters and their objective to
assassinate volo dimmer zelinski the
president of ukraine to cut off the head
of the ukrainian government
whoever could kill zelinski first will
receive a very large bounty and return
to russia as a hero
these soldiers who look at sound
ukrainian work for a company called the
wagner group if you never heard of the
wagner group before it's for a good
reason it's a secretive private military
contractor but not just any private army
these soldiers are unmarked anonymous
they fly no flag many of them are
ex-russian special forces and rumor has
it the wagner group works on behalf of
the russian governments whenever putin
wants a little bit more plausible
deniability and for an entire five weeks
before russia officially invaded ukraine
400 of these wagner mercenaries were
already operating behind enemy lines
these assassins wasted no time in less
than a week after the invasion started
zelinski avoided three assassination
attempts with two of those coming from
wagner mercenaries
besides destabilizing the ukrainian
governments these mercenaries have been
doing the kremlin's bidding all over the
world including syria sudan all over
africa libya venezuela mozambique and
more
since they're unmarked they don't have
to worry about human rights or
collateral damage leaving a trail of war
crimes behind them
this is the wagner group the most
secretive private military in the world
also known as russia's ghost soldiers
[Music]
[Music]
if you watch this channel you're
probably an ambitious person and as an
ambitious person you probably have
crypto and digital wallets that you need
to protect and for good reason cyber
attacks and phishing attempts are more
likely to target you that is where
guardio comes in a free browser
extension that over a million users
trust to protect their private info
while they surf the web it's kind of
like having an online bodyguard in your
browser that protects all your
information like your address bank
details and passwords the cool thing
about guardio is that it detects threats
before they cause harm other services
just remove threats after they've
already infected your device here's how
it works first you add guardio's browser
extension from the chrome store or the
edge store after installing guardio will
run a free security scan that only takes
30 seconds to detect any threats in your
browser once the scan finishes you can
continue on a 7-day free trial to remove
threats and try out their real-time
protection but whether you're a free or
premium user you can access your
dashboard anytime to re-run the scan and
track your activity while guardio is
installed it protects your information
online prevents you from installing
malware and even helps you avoid
internet scams it saves you from
phishing websites email and tech support
scams and annoying push notifications so
you never have to worry about the links
you click on ever again with guardio you
can protect up to five family members on
one account plus it's super easy to use
and affordable so take control of your
online safety in just a few clicks by
going to guard.ios jam for a free
security scan and a 7 day free trial and
guardio offers a money back guarantee so
go to guard.iosajtran with the link
below thanks to guardio for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
private military contractors or pmcs are
nothing new
blackwater now known as academy was the
most well-known controversial american
pmc in the world we have a video in them
the main difference between blackwater
and the wagner group is that the wagner
group doesn't technically exist as far
as we know it's led by a guy named
dmitry yukin an ex-russian special
forces officer he's rumored to be a
neo-nazi and a die-hard hitler fan which
is why wagner the name of hitler's
favorite composer became his call sign
back when he was still in military
intelligence when he left to start his
own business it only made sense to name
his company after wagner as well but
like i said the wagner group as a pmc
doesn't actually exist in russia it's
actually illegal to run a private
military contractor company in russia so
instead the wagner group is registered
in argentina and instead of having
employees wagner is just an umbrella
name for dozens of different russian
pmcs who get their money from one guy
yiv jinny pregazon
also known as putin's chef yes like an
actual cooking chef
eve jenny pakistan is a russian oligarch
and a recent addition to the fbi's most
wanted list he is believed to be the
real owner of the wagner group although
he's always the nine indie association
for obvious reasons he is the money man
and wherever wagner goes pregnant
nonprofits
together yukin and pregazon created this
organization of russian mercenaries to
do whatever the russian government needs
them to do they get a lot of money and
putin avoids getting accused of
committing acts of war against sovereign
countries pmcs are illegal in russia
remember the russian government
obviously can't be held responsible for
something an illegal organization did
plus the wagner group isn't even
registered in russia the connection
between the russian government and
wagner is hazy at most except for the
fact that the weiner group regularly
uses russian military aircraft its
mercenaries get treated in russian
military hospitals and yves jenny
pregnancy and vladimir putin are pretty
much best friends
the wagner group is there for putin to
outsource his dirty work and their very
first job friend was right where they
are today ukraine
[Music]
february 20 2014 russian troops crossed
the border into cremia the ukrainian
peninsula they're here to stake russia's
claim on the territory luckily most
residents of cremia are russian so they
don't pose the threats but in between
the sea of smiling russian soldiers and
marked uniforms were men in plain green
unmarked uniforms they're not smiling as
they move through the cities securing
borders and checkpoints in fact their
faces are completely covered
these were the original wagner
mercenaries later called little green
men because of their unmarked uniforms
they're there to make sure nothing goes
wrong luckily the takeover of crimea was
effortless but in case things got out of
hand the wagner group was there to do
what official russian soldiers couldn't
to make sure that at any cost russia
didn't lose dmitry yukin was one of
those green men back in 2014 after they
took over crimea war broke out in the
eastern region of ukraine dunbas and
around 300 mercenaries moved from crimea
to dambass they were putin's insurance
his backup plan if anyone showed any
sort of resistance they stayed in
ukraine for almost a year waiting for
something to go wrong for a chance to
get in the fights but they wouldn't get
their chance until 2015 when putin
suddenly needed help in syria
[Applause]
hamdi bhuta was not the kind of man to
look for trouble when things in syria
started getting bad in 2011 he decided
to cut his losses and flee to lebanon
his wife and children would be safe in
syria but if he stayed there was a
chance he would be forced to join the
syrian army and fight against the rebels
if he was forced to fight who would care
for his kids who would make sure they
had money so for almost six years he
stayed put in lebanon away from his
family regularly sending money to his
wife and dreaming of the day he could go
back home then right before a major
religious holiday in 2017 his mother
died and being a family man he decided
it was time to visit home except he
never got a chance to do any of that
instead as he reached the capital of
syria damascus he was detained by syrian
soldiers when they found out he fled in
2011 they informed him that he would
have to join the army his worst fears
were coming true he would have to fight
against his own countrymen and no one
would be there to take care of his
family so he hatched a plan once he
reached the army base he would just run
he didn't know the area well but he
didn't care he would just keep running
until he found someone who could help
and that's exactly what he did the only
problem was hamdi underestimated how far
he had to run but he kept going
exhausted and dehydrated until he saw a
camp in the distance he was saved he was
going to make it relief flooded his body
as he ran into the camp calling out in
arabic the only language he knew except
the people in the camp weren't syrian in
fact they weren't arabic at all they
spoke a language he couldn't understand
and pointed guns in his face hamdi had
just stumbled into a wagner group camp
outside of the aoshara gas plants
you see two years earlier russia had
made a deal with the syrian governments
for every oil or gas plant they freed
from rebel control certain russian
companies will receive 25 percent of the
plant's proceeds in the ao share plants
where the wagner group was stationed had
become a cash cow for a company called
evropolis coincidentally avril polis is
directly linked to none other than
evgeny pregozan the owner of the wagner
group
so when hamdi bhuta ran into their camp
that day he could have never expected
what would happen next instead of
helping him trying to understand a story
or even just arresting him the wagner
mercenaries did much worse they accused
him of being part of isis their
justification he could only speak arabic
what happened next is sickening so
sickening that i can't talk about it on
youtube or else we will get demonetized
you can read it for yourself by
searching hamdi buta's name
in the end hamdi bhuta was brutally
killed treated in the same way
terrorists treated westerners and it was
all caught on camera a camera held by a
wagner mercenary as they tortured a
completely innocent man
all of that for around four thousand
dollars a month while russia claims it's
only giving syria aerial supports the eu
council later found dmitry yukin had
personally ordered the mercenaries to do
what they did and get it on camera and
syria was not their only customer
who do you call when you just overthrown
your country's governments and need to
make sure your coup doesn't get cooed
that you won't just get overthrown by
someone else while there's still a power
vacuum you call the wagner group of
course just like president assad of
syria the governments of african
countries like mali sudan and the
central african republic they all use
wider mercenaries to stay in power
weiner mercenary's first touchdown in
the central african republic or car in
2017. the car has been at war with
itself for years every few months
there's a new coup attempt every year
there's opportunity for a civil war and
for years the main military force in the
area were un peacekeeping troops
unfortunately for them by 2017 they had
not kept much peace or done anything to
stabilize the governments so the
president of the car decided to turn to
russia it was time to call in the big
dogs so wagner arrived in the car to
train his army boost their security
commit a few war crimes in the process
and make a lot of money for its founder
evgeny pragazan
around 2 000 wagner mercenaries were
stationed in the car but instead of
fighting against armed troops they're
mostly there to serve russia's financial
interests and their own bloodlust in
fact the mercenaries often work with the
people they're supposed to be fighting
against to buy locally mined diamonds
instead it's no secret who is profiting
in 2021 the car prime minister flew to
russia on pakistan's own private jets
all over africa russian companies like
those owned by pergazon are profiting
big time from wagner's expansion oil
diamonds coal gold you name it in gaza
prickazine have their fingers all over
it it's one of the reasons why african
countries are so slow to call out russia
for invading ukraine and why people like
jacob zuma ex-president of south africa
post stuff like this on twitter even
calling putin a man of peace russia's
support even at the expense of their own
people and resources is too valuable to
lose
[Music]
in 2018 three russian journalists
traveled to the car for a very special
project to investigate what the wagner
group has been up to in the country they
went in expected to get a small glimpse
of how putin's private army operated
they were going to share this
information with the world and left the
veil off of one of the most ruthless and
feared pmc's in the world but they never
got the chance three days after their
arrival the three journalists were on
their way to meet a source but then a
group of men appeared out of nowhere and
opened fire on their car it was an
ambush the three journalists were dead
in an instance
people expected public outcry russia is
famous for making big waves whenever
russian citizens are harmed or killed
overseas but none of that happened
instead the russian government came out
with a news story these three
journalists had no authorization to be
in the car they hadn't gotten approval
or support from the russian forces in
the car they had gone in blind and they
knew it it wasn't russia's faults they
couldn't help people who didn't follow
the right channels the three journalists
were supposed to take protection from
the same people they were investigating
and the government of the cer also
deflected the story first the government
claimed the journalists were killed by
roadside robbers then their driver who
survived the attack pretty much fell off
the face of the earth and to top it all
off russia then put all the blame on the
man who funded their journalism trip
none other than mikhail kortakovsky and
if you've watched our video on russian
oligarchs you would know that mikhail
kardakovsky was a russian oil tycoon who
made billions but then a couple years
into his reign as russia's richest man
he decided to take on vladimir putin for
corruption in exchange he got sent to
jail then a labor camp had all of his
wealth destroyed and now lives in exile
in switzerland mikhail always had alfred
putin in his governments maybe
investigating the wagner group was how
he hoped to stick it to putin luckily
for russia the journalists never got the
chance to uncover anything murdered on a
busy road where no one else was attacked
for weeks before or after that
for all we know about the war crimes
wagner mercenaries commits there's very
little we actually know about its
tactics or how it operates in the
countries it visits the wagner group is
the world's most bloodthirsty secret of
pmc and they're not going to give out
that title anytime soon
[Music]
you